you're a student of the game if aaron
judge hits 62 home runs or more is he
the authentic home run champion
oh man that is a very tough question i i
you know i i think you know we just
touched on it just the history of this
game there's so much history i think
it's really hard to compare eras um you
know and uh that barry bonds era is a
unique distinction in this game um you
know the roger maris before that was a
different time as well i mean you put
roger maris in today's game um or babe
ruth in today's game with everybody
coming out of the bullpen throwing 100
miles an hour you know who knows what
they're able to accomplish so i think we
need to really appreciate what what
judge is doing right now in this era on
his own i mean i it's you know i i think
it's
you know i think there's two separate
uh numbers though you know there's
there's there's rogers and there's
berries and um
you know i i think to be able to reach
uh marissa's i i think should be
celebrated um because that that that uh
you know the 90s era was just a
different era of baseball it's you know
live ball you've got live ballet or a
dead ball or a steroid era whatever era
it is um but it's really fun to see
what he's able to do and and
and bring attention to this game you
know that's what it's all about so i
can't really answer that question but i
think it should definitely be celebrated
if he patches passes marissa's record
you